so these courses have come out of this
collaborative conversation about
feminist pedagogy and these are the
ideas of what what we would like to do
together
there were okay so there's a graphic
that we produced about the different
notion of a doc from a MOOC and what we
had was a network of 18 nodal sites
through 15 institutions and again as the
som discovered it worked better to have
individual professors at specific places
teach their individual courses but to
also develop through collaborative work
some of the materials that we shared and
some of the course assignments there
were great hopes to do some things like
Wikipedia storming what it's very
difficult to edit Wikipedia from outside
of the small group of people at the top
making decisions of in Wikipedia and
Wikipedia which is the digital archive
of the world's future leaves out a great
deal of information and in particular
the topic of this course feminism and
technology it leaves out whole histories
of women in computing women in all kinds
of other technological innovations and
so we envisioned a collaboration of
course the 18 nodal sites fifteen
institutions three community groups
there was also one in Second Life
so that's not on the slide but we
envisioned projects in which people
would learn to edit from edit Wikipedia
and we had one of the senior women
editors there are very few because they
quit very quickly once they get to that
level but it was unwieldy to manage and
we we didn't figure out how to manage it
Fox News did a presentation about us
making fun of us for injecting feminism
into Wikipedia so we made some kind of a
splash but that needs to be rethought
the technology was our was our
we didn't use Adobe the Adobe meeting we
used a specific proprietorial
proprietary ol site that was developed
at Hunter and I'm afraid it just
couldn't take the number of people so
the robustness of that technology is one
of the limiting factors of this but
within how what we did do we it
succeeded tremendously well we had 100%
virtually 100% success rate
we made here's a here's a photograph of
our class we had scholars in person
visiting and we also there were a set of
11 or 12 video dialogues that were
produced throughout the semester with
experts often a senior and a junior
person but not only divided by age also
paired in other ways on topics of the
course there were collaborative projects
these are some of them I helped write
the white paper I helped write grants I
did some presentations and workshops I
did an open office hour and those also
worked very well and here are plans for
the future we are working now on on in
enhancing Yale's efforts in this along
with the University of Michigan which
has given a good deal of resources to
their participation in the in the
femtechnet and the doc and digital
humanities pedagogy we're looking
forward to us developing metrics or
assessment better platforms for
interaction and of course to continue to
create the content which is coming in
massively from all sides because this is
truly a this is truly a as opposed to
proprietary information this is open and
shared information and people are
joining this at a great rate this is a
truly collaborative
organized course
so I also another thing that was great
about Yale is that instructional
technology and trip have given us a lot
of resources so that this this course
had a lab connected to it
a two-hour lab in the evening and on top
of the two-hour seminar in which the
students were taught to use the digital
platforms that would allow them to make
their final project and their final
project is to make a digital street
somewhere else from here and some time
other than now to use the Yale resources
in the libraries the the archival
richness of Yale to imagine and to
picture that Street but to create a
product a digital product and that
needed to be run by Tripp so I'll let
him come in talk a little bit about this
thank you so right so Laurence mentioned
a little bit about the structure of the
lab we met every week except for a
shopping period in the first several
weeks we addressed sort of broken down
media construction problems there were a
wide range of prior experiences of the
students that there was a lot to do to
balance things that students knew how to
do things that students had seen a lot
of but didn't know how to do and then
think the students didn't know how to do
at all
so some of these examples were basic
media remixes basic imagery mixing we
spent an really wonderful class talking
about the animated gif we went along I
love it because it's great it elicits
this smile and a lot of people's faces
but it really is wonderful to start
breaking down the sort of what you could
call a basic chunk of internet rhetoric
that is the animated gif as well as the
what gets called a cinema graph usually
it's kind of it seems to want to be
moved into this realm of high art but in
a lot of ways technologically it's the
same thing so we looked at those and how
to create these and
students might incorporate these into
their projects we did have one student
who at first in fact was going to do his
entire project and animated gifts but
that didn't end up happening we did
sound transformations basic video
editing and a quick flyby with markup
after that we moved into much more open
time when students could express their
interest their problems they were having
the term project formulation is very
elegant but over the last two years I've
been with this course for two years it's
been offered three times the students
often have a bit of the terror of the
blank page it's a very elegant
formulation but what does that actually
mean a street some other time then now
somewhere else than here
vo students are very creative and
aggressive in their thinking and so they
come up with all these possibilities so
part of lab also is this low hum of just
project management it's just get this
done so part of my job was to move them
from the terror of the blank page to a
final project because done is better
than not done
we did have some visiting speakers come
in in the flesh you saw a little bit in
that picture from the library on
research overview somebody came in from
the printers office to talk about design
thinking and one thing I wouldn't mind
seeing in the future is seeing how we
can take the resources we have here and
see who else is interested in using our
resources Checotah from the printers
office is an amazing thinker and design
thinker and I'd love to be able to help
other people gain access to her
knowledge and experience a couple things
on the scholarship we I mentioned a
little bit of it with it with the notion
of the gift so one of my goals with the
Media Lab was to get the students to D
familiarize themselves with this
internet media technology world that
they inhabit they swim in it but I was
tell people Yale is one of the great
examples of the myth of the digital
native my encounters with students are
that they know what they know and they
know how to do these basic things but
they don't really interrogate it that
much so we wanted to help them and
interrogate these tools these
environments that they
use one of the ways I do that is to use
open source tools as much as possible to
get them to think about why tool makers
might have the agendas they have why
open source advocates might have the
agendas they have Wikipedia is a great
example of that and that's embedded in
the rest of the course and to get them
to begin creating if they don't already
to get them reflect on their creation
processes if they're already creating
basically to think about the water which
doesn't always happen so just in closing
what are some examples of some digital
streets that have happened well one was
a pathway in Jamaica at the moment of
emancipation from a from a plantation to
the market and that used archives from
the British Center for British art one
of them was Oh a journey of two avatars
through Disneyland Tokyo on opening day
one that was actually pretty effective
this year was a tour this also brings up
a little bit of a problem letting
students go with letting students go
public it was a tour around the
perimeter of Yale so Yale streets are on
the perimeter of Yale there were maybe
eight people that went on this tour we
are each supplied an iPod we each heard
a soundtrack for this tour some of us
were laughing some of us were pensive we
learned at the end that we didn't have
the same soundtrack although we had the
same tour which is making a point about
what the digital world sherry turkle's
point about living in the digital world
- alone together but what the tour was
were places where there had been over
the past 10 or 15 years where there had
been crimes committed in the perimeter
of Yale and so we I made a Fiat of a
decision that that would not go online
because I'm not sure that we want to
talk about how many crimes there were
we're not there weren't actually all
that many we have to discuss this if
you're gonna let students to their own
work what you're gonna also
commit to what they want to say about
Yale and I don't know yet where we're
working on making this into a film but I
don't know yet exactly what to do with
it this is a feminist course it works
without law knowledge sexuality violence
things like that it eventually will have
to learn how to make things public but
at this point I didn't really know so
you can't see that but it was a terrific
project okay thank you